là pour soutenir françois baroin et les
candidats de la droite et du centre afin
de donner une majorité à notre pays et
en os les candidats elle est réuni pour
les élections législatives
nous avons besoin de gagner ces
initiatives pour apporter une majorité à
la france on peut avoir une opposition
constructive
c'est possible on est vraiment dans une
démarche de retenez de redonner du
pouvoir d'achat et une relance de
l'économie sur le terrain plus proche
des français on va pouvoir parler du
programme de la baisse des impôts de la
sécurité tous et tous les sujets qui
intéressent les français aujourd'hui
voilà pourquoi je suis là aujourd'hui
pour pour soutenir ce programme un
programme une vision des idées pour
notre pays et il est temps maintenant de
parler du fond macro a gagné la bataille
de l'ambiguïté et nous on va gagner la
bataille de la clarté on va s'investir à
fond sur le terrain pour obtenir un
maximum de députés
il incarne parfaitement et de passion si
talentueuse cette génération qui se lève
ils portent cette volonté d'engagement
total au service de notre pays ils sont
le visage de la france ils sont de
droite et du centre et ils en sont fiers
[Applaudissements]
ils sont nos candidats ils portent nos
espoirs
ils font les candidats de la majorité
pour la franche
ils portent notre projet ils le
défendent bec et ongles sur le terrain
au plus près les françaises et les
français c'est maintenant mes chers amis
qu'il faut se mobiliser
rien n'est joué ne laissez personne
décider à votre place c'est dans 3
semaines que tout se joue
on va s'engager avant on à ces
législatives et on va les gagner
les 11 et 18 juin prochains
donnons une majorité pour la franche
pour que vive la république
et pour que vive la france
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]